مقزومه خائفا وغاض بيتحركوا في كل
الاتجاهات لكن حيز الفاعليه لاسكات صرخه
الحريه والحياه والمراه من قبلهما يضيق
النظام المعزول السائمه الداخل وسطوته
بالصبغه المتشدده والديكتاتوريه التي
تفرضها العباءه ترهقه اليوم روتينيه احراق
الرموز او الصور وانسيبيه اسقاط العمامه
حتى في عمقه الفارسي واكثر ما يخيفه هو
كسر الخوف ومشاهد مواجهه سلاحه في الشوارع
بايد المحتاجين
داخليا وبعد تهمه التخوين بالاجنده
الاجنبيه يحمل المتظاهرين الان مسؤوليه
الضغوط والعقبات ويلجاوا الى الاعدامات
العلنيه منها على هاتف
المنخفضه وتخيفه ولنا وقفه مع الاعداء لكن
السؤال الان لماذا لا يقدم النظام الخائف
تنازلات وكيف يفكر
يعلم جيدا كالمحتاجين انه لا يمكن اختزاله
الازمه وكان شرطه الاخلاق هي المشكله
وحلها هو الحل بل تكشف بسبب الفوضى داخل
نخبه نظام ان ذلك لا يعدو كونه تكتيكا
للاستعاده السيطره قانون الزاميه الحجاب
لن يسقط حتى وان تتم رجعته في البرلمان
الان القانون هو احد الاسس الرئيسيه
للنظام وغطاء الراس ايقونه ثورته في
1979 التنازل عنه بنظره سيكون بوابه
الحريه للايرانيين الشباب منهم الذين تكشف
مطالبهم شيخوخه الثوره الخشيه الاكبر من
مطالب لم تبدا مع الانتفاضه سبتمبر
يعلم النظام منذ 2018 على الاقل لان نسبه
تاييد غطاء الراس قدم خفضت في السنوات
التي اعقبت الثوره من 85% الى
35% نسبه يمكن اسقاطها وموازاتها بتاييد
النظام بيحدداته يعلم ونعلم ذلك لان
الارقام رسميه جاءت في بحثا واستطلاعا
لمركز ابحاث البرلمان الايراني ومن
البرلمان تاتين المؤشرات عضو اللجنه
الثقافيه فيها الحليف الديني لخامنئي حسين
جلال
يتباهى بالقدره القمعيه للنظام وقياده
المرشد لاكثر من 100 و90.000 عنصرا في
الحرس الثوري وعشرات الالاف من المسيج
المكلفين بغرس الخوف بين الشعب والمفارقه
لم تجدي هذه الاعداد ونفعا الاعتراف قائد
الحرس الثوري حسين سلامه وذلك خلال ج في
نقاش امام المجلس الاعلى للامن القومي